this year's hurricane season officially
begins today while Puerto Rico is still
recovering from last year's destruction
it could take another two months to
restore power to more than 11,000 people
who've been in the dark since Hurricane
Maria hit more than eight months ago
baby beg no is in San Juan with Puerto
Rico's struggled to come back David good
morning good morning John the start of
hurricane season is front-page news here
on the island you know there are
hurricane ravaged homes like this one
right here which remain abandoned it
would be inaccurate to report this story
and not tell you that things have gotten
better they have 4-1 officials promise
us they are better prepared if you land
in San Juan today you'll find most
people going about their lives regularly
but just outside the capital it is
impossible to miss the misery nice to
meet you that's Jose Sepulveda
he's a bedridden cancer survivor whose
wife calls him on the front porch every
day because the heat is insufferable
inside they haven't had electricity
since last September no power for eight
months
no and hurricane season might have now
begun yes are you ready for another
season no no how can we be ready we have
no life that's his wife Aloha it's not
easy at some times I start crying but a
night I got a lord up there he helps me
they live in Yabba koa where hurricane
maria made landfall 38% of people still
don't have power here across the island
11,000 people are still waiting Carlos
Reyes got so frustrated waiting he
restored his own power
the Puerto Rico grid is teetering what
government official said
despite 3.8 billion dollars in repairs
relief workers are stepping in
installing solar panels including this
one at the home of Cecilia Burgos the
energy is being used to power this
refrigerator it's one of the first
things people ask and you help me keep
my food cool it's also powering this fan
that they leave off during the day to
preserve the energy they have and most
importantly at night they use the
generator to power the fan over
Cecilia's bed Mike Byrne has led FEMA's
response after Maria last year we had
about 80 generators we're gonna have 630
generators here on the island we will do
whatever it takes to take care of
whatever comes our way
in the meantime they wait we need your
help and please never forget us thank
you that we won't we won't get this
after Maria Harvard researchers estimate
that on average every household went 84
days without power and 68 days without
water and Gail it bears repeating
Harvard estimates 4,600 people died
because of that store boy David that's
tough to hear and I love the woman
saying don't forget us and you telling
her we won't cuz you're right we won't
especially as long as you're there
bringing the story to us thank you David
Beck no reporting from Puerto Rico once
again